- Ah.
- Here we go, perfect.
- [Mark] All right, Ernie.
Ernie, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from? Originally?
Where'd you grow up?
- Cuba and New Mexico.
White Horse Lake.
- [Mark] In New Mexico?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And tell me about your family.
You're Navajo?
- My mom's Navajo.
But my dad's a Cheyenne Native.
- [Mark] Cheyenne?
- North of, north of Cheyenne.
That's where my dad's from.
But they like each other.
- [Mark] How was your childhood?
- I don't know what's going on.
But mom's gone.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- I came into town,
started drinking.
I'm feeling ham.
- [Mark] When did you
start drinking alcohol?
- Oh, my first time?
I was 13 years old.
- [Mark] Thirteen.
- Mama had her bar in the home.
I didn't know.
That was in Denver.
Her and my dad, they had their bar open.
Then one day,
I had a friend.
It was a hot boy on the
side, on the street.
(Sigh)
(Inaudible)
They left. Hey, my mom left,
for the weekend.
I didn't drink nothing.
Then the little boy came by.
He said "Why, why don't
you try that whiskey?".
And we did. That's why I started to drink.
- [Mark] Whiskey, at 13?
What is your drink-
- I-
- [Mark] What is your drink today?
- (inaudible)
- [Mark] Vodka?
- Well, now it's turned to Vodka.
- [Mark] Could you drink
some of the other things
that people will use to get drunk?
Like, like hairspray
and Gatorade or Lysol?
Or what else, what other
stuff, what other things
did you-
- I stole it!
- [Mark] You stole what?
- Hairspray, Lysol.
I did all that stuff.
- [Mark] You drink it? It
gets you, it gets you drunk?
- Huh? (inaudible)
- [Mark] What about
like, things like perfume
or rubbing alcohol?
- I did it. I did it.
- [Mark] What's the
difference between vodka and
and rubbing alcohol, or perfume?
- Uh...
- [Mark] Or Lysol.
- Same thing.
- [Mark] Same thing?
It just gets you high?
- Gets drunk.
- [Mark] Yeah.
And you sleep on the street?
It gets cold at night, no?
- No. I've been on the street.
- [Mark] Oh, in the
winter it gets very cold
there in New Mexico.
- Yep.
People die sometimes from that, right?
- I know.
But, I did all that,
and I'm trying to go home.
I'm (inaudible)
- [Mark] What do you do for money?
How do you, how do you get money?
- Just every day-
- [Mark] You just panhandle?
- Drinking.
- [Mark] But you pan,
you ask people, you-you-
you beg for money and
people give it to you?
- I make money.
- [Mark] How do you make money?
- Panhandle.
I make money and then...
some days is good, and other days not.
- [Mark] Do you have children?
- I have nobody.
- [Mark] No family, no friends, no?
- I only have one. My sister.
- [Mark] Your sister's all you have left?
- (crying) I have my brother too.
I just drink.
My brother's quarantined
over there at that Motel.
He's supposed to get
out today or tomorrow.
- [Mark] Did you once
live on a reservation?
- Huh?
- [Mark] Did you once live
on an Indian reservation?
- Nah, I had a reservation. Mine.
It's, it's different.
We pay for our lands.
I'm not on the reservation.
I paid for my lands,
where I live.
These guys, Arizona.
They don't pay nothing for it.
But I paid for mine.
Then now,
we got oil, whatever.
Oil, coal, water.
That's all we got to pay with now.
And then I'll go out to,
my dad's from Montana.
- [Mark] The Cheyenne part of your family?
- We're fighters, (inaudible)!
- I don't know if you guys know.
We don't, we don't retreat.
We don't retreat, I said.
Shit, I don't know.
We fight.
My uncles and...
(crying)
(inaudible)
They said that we...
Um...
But they blame...
I didn't make (inaudible) with my Aunt.
They killed her out there!
They threw her in the pit, in the wash.
Some wash out there.
- [Mark] She died in the, on the street?
- Yep. They killed her!
- [Mark] Oh, they killed her?
- Cause she would,
she stood up for us!
They found her body over there.
And now my brother's over there.
(inaudible)
- Yep. I'm not scared.
They can kill me.
I'm not giving (inaudible)
to the Government.
They know me. They know my family!
We're (inaudible)!
I can't...
They can kill me, I don't care.
They did it to my grandma too!
My grandma!
(sobbing)
Grandma.
- [Mark] For many reasons, it's
hard to be Native American,
isn't it today?
(cries out)
- We have our rights!
We're not scared!
I'm not scared of them. They
can fucking kill me right now.
I'm ready for it.
(heavy breathing)
I'm not scared of them.
(crying)
I don't know what they did to my family.
But, they're gone.
And I'm done here!
My mom! My mom's family on this side.
- [Mark] Okay Ernie, well
thank you for talking with me.
Appreciate it.
- Well, it's right there.
- [Mark] Thank you.